in just a few seconds this car will hit
that concrete wall and when it does the
front end will crush like a soda can
there will be an explosive chemical
reaction and the occupants will continue
moving forward
it looks like absolute chaos but it's
all by design this is a car crash this
is damage control if you've ever been in
a car crash
you know it's instantaneous impact can
take as little as 24 milliseconds that's
faster than we can blink to slow things
down we went to the Insurance Institute
for Highway Safety to crash some cars
the test you're gonna see today is our
frontal small overlap test on the
driver's side in all of our high-speed
crash tests we're testing three
different things in cars one is the
structure of cars the second is the
airbags and restraint systems and the
third is the injury measures that we get
from the dummies
[Music]
when we develop a new crash-test we are
continually looking at the real world
data we're looking at fatality databases
we're looking at in-depth in-depth crash
investigation studies to look at how
people are being injured and killed the
types of crashes and understanding that
really helps us fill the gaps of where
we need to go next to push safety
further what we learned is that every
crash has three collisions one car hits
barrier two body hits car three organs
hit body the ultimate safety design goal
of any car is to manage the first two in
order to minimize the third to keep the
passengers safe cars do a
counterintuitive thing they make the
crash last as long as possible
a crash happens when you go from some
speed to zero in a very short amount of
time you don't want the occupants to
experience that deceleration from 40 to
zero in a very short time you're not
able to to use your brakes to slow down
effectively if you can spread out the
deceleration over that time then you
have a good chance of surviving the
first level is making sure that the
vehicle safe you're hitting a rigid wall
doesn't stop right away so you want that
vehicle to absorb some energy and come
to a controlled stop one technique for
improving protection in these kinds of
crashes is to disperse energy across the
front end of the vehicle where people
aren't sitting but then you want a
strong structure around the occupants of
the car we don't want any energy being
dispersed in there and structures being
pushed back towards the people inside
[Music]
when you look at crashes of older cars
you see the results of their more rigid
construction uncontrolled chaos rigid
objects transfer kinetic energy
effectively make a car too rigid and the
passengers will take on more of the
force from the crash to counterbalance
the parts that must be rigid Engineers
find places that can yield without
harming the passengers you do have very
controlled points in the front-end
structure that will collapse and usually
in a very predictable way in certain
types of crashes to help absorb some of
that energy and that's what we call
crumple zones if you have a situation
where that occupant is slowed down too
quickly you can have severe injuries to
the skeletal system the bones and the
soft tissues of the brain inside the
skull in the abdomen and the chest
really during the crash you have the
vehicle deforming the occupant moving
forward and then finally when the
occupant stops a lot of what we see
mainly these days has a lot of times we
see orthopedic injuries depending on the
scope of the accident or a solid organ
injury like your liver kidney spleen or
where we have combinations related to
the location of the injury where you
might have a bad fracture like the bones
around your hips that also injure the
bladder and/or the rectum or the colon
or small intestines and it depends on
really the speed
at this moment the car is decelerating
violently but you're not part of the car
and physics wants your body to keep
moving forward so the new challenge is
to manage the second collision to slow
your body down way down this is where
seat belts and airbags come into play
car crash safety is kind of like
packaging 101 when you're shipping a
fragile object how would you ship it the
first thing you want to have is a strong
structure around the object the second
thing is you want to have cushioning
materials things like airbags and
seatbelts to keep the object from
bouncing around within that strong box
and the third is you the object inside
of the car
no matter what car you're riding in the
seat belt is the number one thing you
can do to protect yourself in a crash
seat belts are central in restraining
you further slowing you down
while simultaneously extending the
duration of the crash
so today's seat belts are actually
designed to give just a bit with the
body during forward movement the load
limiter is a mechanical device that just
senses too much loading by your body and
lets out a little slack and then when it
senses a little more loading let's out a
little more slack if that occupant
decelerates too quickly you're gonna
have some issues right because either
the occupant hits a steering wheel or
the seat belt in a manner that is it's
too hard too fast and so you want to
make sure the airbags and the seat belts
control some of that slowdown to make
sure you mitigate the potential for
injury the last line of defense in a car
crash the airbags are a lot more complex
than meets the eye they are triggered by
chemical explosion and expand outward
faster than the blink of an eye they're
not just the big pillowy thing that
inflates they inflated they have vent
holes and as the occupant moves forward
into them it absorbs energy it vents
some of the gas out so that you're not
just hitting a very hard rigid structure
and this brings us to the third and
final collision even though your body is
slowing down your organs are still
traveling forward
even though cars are becoming safer and
safer our body as still traveling and
the physics behind these things are very
susceptible to these internal injuries a
lot of it depends on the mechanism the
forces are basically the physics of it
and also the location of where the
passenger is once we get into higher
speed accidents we see a lot of
combination of solid organ injuries and
brain injuries of what we call kind of a
poly trauma patient and it involves more
than just an isolated injury to an
extremity or one organ at a time the
best way to lessen this impact and
potential for serious harm is to use
design to harness the uncontrollable
rather than designing an unbreakable car
have a crumple better then lock the body
in place let it move if people walk away
from a crash unharmed it's because a
combination of things have occurred
number one the vehicle did its job in
terms of structure it kept a strong
structure around the person the
restraint systems did their job in
protecting the person from hitting
things inside the car and the person was
probably wearing their seatbelt
no matter the speed once a car crashes
the sole engineering goal is to
decelerate the body and save your life
it's never gentle but the longer it
lasts the safer you are cars do this by
employing a complex system of controlled
self destruction self destruction that
hopefully keeps you alive